>> Tucker: AMEN, THAT IS
REASSURING TO HEAR, THANK YOU.
YOU MIGHT THINK YOU.
>> Tucker: OF A LOT OF
CONSEQUENCES WE HAVEN’T THOUGHT
THROUGH OF THIS PANDEMIC AND ONE
OF THEM IS COUNTRIES TO OUR
SOUTH COULD BE DESTABILIZED BY
IT AND YOU COULD SEE A SURGE, A
BIG SURGE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
COME UP FROM LATIN AMERICA.
THAT DOES HAPPEN, AND ABSOLUTELY
COULD HAPPEN, WE PREPARED TO
DEAL WITH IT?
MARK MORGAN AS ACTING
COMMISSIONER OF CUSTOMS AND
BORDER PROTECTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THIS DOES NOT SEEM LIKE A CRAZY
POSSIBILITY.
TO PROTECT THE POPULATION
FLOUTING ANY SUGGESTION THAT
THEY LOCK ANYONE DOWN.
THEY COULD HAVE MASSIVE PROBLEMS
WITH THIS, WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN
FOR US?
>> IT IS NOT HYPERBOLE TO THINK
OF THAT.
BUT WHAT I WANT THE LISTENERS TO
KNOW, THIS ISN’T THE FIRST
INFECTIOUS DISEASE CRISIS.
SARS, H1 N1 AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES, WE HOPE
FOR THE BEST, WE PLAN FOR THE
WORSE AND THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT
WE’RE DOING NOW.
THAT COULD BE A POSSIBILITY SO
WE ARE TAKING AGGRESSIVE
CONTAINMENT AND MITIGATION
STRATEGIES NOW TO HELP STEM THAT
IF THAT SHOULD BECOME A
POSSIBILITY IN THE PRESENT
AUTHORITY AND HIS AGREEMENT WITH
THE CDC ORDER LAST FRIDAY IS
DOING JUST THAT AND IN SIX DAYS,
IT’S AMAZING WHAT WE’VE
ACCOMPLISHED.
THE OVERALL PEOPLE TRYING TO
ENTER OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY IN
SIX DAYS BECAUSE OF THE CDC’S
ORDER THAT THE PRESIDENT
APPROVED HAS DROPPED 50%.
AND ANOTHER KEY STAT IF YOU
DON’T MIND AS OUR VEHICULAR
TRAFFIC AND ARE PEDESTRIANS.
MOST OF THE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN BORDER HAS DROPPED BY
OVER 65%.
THAT MEANS MEXICAN CITIZENS AND
THE CANADIAN CITIZENS IN CELLS
ARE SELF POLICING.
WHEN ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING
IN ILLEGALLY FROM MEXICO AND
CANADA.
ARE YOU SEEING IT DROP THE LAST
THREE YEARS FROM EMMA KRATZ
WHICH IS IT’S IMMORAL TO KEEP
ANYBODY OUT, TO ENFORCE BORDERS
THEMSELVES BECAUSE NO ONE IS
ILLEGAL, ARE PEOPLE SAYING LESS
OF THAT KIND OF NONSENSE NOW
THAT THE CORONAVIRUS IS HERE?
>> IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE FOR
A LONG TIME, WE HAVE BEEN SAYING
BORDERS MATTER AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THAT, KILLING
68,000 PEOPLE LAST YEAR, WE HAVE
BAD GUYS, CRIMINALS, GANG
MEMBERS POURING IN BUT WE’VE
ALSO BEEN SAYING THAT INFECTIOUS
DISEASE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
IS A REAL THREAT AS WELL.
PEOPLE ARE DISMISSING AND NOT
LISTENING BUT THEY ARE LISTENING
NOW.
IT’S THE THIRD PART OF THAT AND
IF THAT’S THE DISEASE, IT’S
IMPORTANT.
AND IT DOES MATTER.
SECURE BORDERS MATTER.
MY BACK AS WE JUST SAW IN A
SEGMENT WE DID ON NEW YORK,
LEADERS IN SOME PLACES DON’T
CARE IF YOU GET SICK.
THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO PROTECT
YOU BECAUSE IT MAKES THEM FEEL